[Music]
if anybody is watching this thank you so
much I'm actually on the set of a music
video right now so I'm in this like
trailer and and the meowing is Benjamin
Taylor Swift revealing in her new song
the archer during her latest Instagram
lives its track 5 on the album which
Swifties know is notoriously the most
personal song on her albums I really
wanted to give you track 5 before the
album came out so track 5 is kind of a
tradition that has that really started
with you guys because I didn't realize I
was doing this but as I was making
albums I guess I don't I don't know why
but instinctively I was just kind of
putting a very vulnerable personal
honest emotional song as track 5 like my
first album track 5 was called cold as
you my second album fearless track 5 was
Whitehorse my third album speak now was
a song called Dear John my fourth album
red was a song called all too well track
5 on 1989 was all you had to do was stay
and reputations tracked by with
delicates so because you noticed this I
kind of started to like put the songs
that were really honest emotional and
vulnerable and personal as track 5 so
that that has definitely happened in the
case of track 5 on
Taylor says she did the song with her
pal Jack Antonoff who she often creates
hits with and yeah she's been leaving
Easter eggs like this moment in that you
need to calm down video there have been
a lot of Easter eggs that have been
pointing to this song because I love
this song so much there were Cupid's
playing in the band during the me music
video there were there there have been
arrows pretty much everywhere I've been
drawing arrows through hearts and stuff
and then the most obvious Easter Egg my
friend Haley was kind enough to unveil
that Easter Egg and then you need to
calm down video Haley was doing archery
and the arrow hits the bull's eye that
says five Taylor also revealed her
Diaries would be part of her four deluxe
albums to honor the fact she's been
making music for 13 years
you know her favorite number I've been
writing in Diaries since I was 13 years
old and I've written about pretty much
everything that's happened to me um and
you know I've written my original lyrics
in those Diaries just feelings you know
lessons things you go through and that's
been one of my ways of coping with
things I need to either write songs or
write something in order to like process
life good times and bad and so I want to
show you something these are the deluxe
editions of the album and there are four
of them and in them are a hundred and
twenty pages of my diaries and to give
you an example of that like here's my
actual diary here's what's in the deluxe
edition so they're just they're just
scammed and so it's you know it's
everything from one second
gonna turn this around again it's
everything from pictures drawn photos of
that time in my life you know I used to
like tape stuff in my Diaries that
stuff's all in there
and so I'm just gonna show you a bit so
basically there's like it's it starts
like this there's there's a full word
that I've written each one of these has
30 pages because there's four so there's
30 pages of journals entries from me in
each one of these and then it goes to
where there's lots of pictures and stuff
and then it goes to your opportunity to
turn this into your journal and like
process things in your life by writing
about them and then at the back of it is
the is the CD and the art and the
booklet and yeah I mean I found some
crazy stuff in there I found like the
original lyrics of all too well which I
didn't even know that I had in my
Diaries so I was like it's everything
from being 13 and coming home from a bad
day at school to you know Grammy night -
you know processing my life changing as
a teenager all that good stuff
Taylor's album lover will be out on
August 23rd
you